next week Britain's nurses will become
the latest group of workers to go on
strike fighting for better pay it's a
landmark moment the first time ever that
UK nurses have walked out but they're
not the only group of workers
complaining that their wages are
unsustainably low border force staff
have now announced a day two will strike
later this month joining rail workers
postal staff teachers and University
lecturers ambulance staff and transport
workers in Parliament the opposition
party challenged the Prime Minister this
morning his transport secretary said
that his Flagship legislation on strikes
this is what he said this morning his
transport secretary might want to listen
to this is clearly is clearly not going
to help with the industrial action we're
facing he should stop grandstanding stop
sitting on his hands get round the table
and resolve these issues the government
has been reasonable it's accepted the
recommendations of an independent paper
body giving pay rise sizes in many cases
higher than the private sector but if
the union leaders to continue to be
unreasonable then it is my duty to take
action to protect the lives and
livelihoods of the British public the
lives and livelihoods of the British
public are being hit by rampant
inflation groceries are 14 more
expensive than a year ago headline
inflation is 11 but most people's wages
are not increasing by the same amount if
at all
an increasing inequality between between
the top wages and the lowest wages so
the highest percentiles and the lowest
percentiles but also the median wages so
it has seen actually an impoverishment
of the middle class the Trade union
unite is currently involved in 22
separate pay disputes it refutes the
idea that companies can't afford to
increase salaries unite research has
shown that over the last year the top
companies in the UK they're profit
margins have increased by two-thirds so
what we actually have now is a crisis of
profiteering a recent UK opinion poll
found 60 percent of people are generally
supportive of workers taking industrial
action especially in the current cost of
living crisis but that figure did vary
sector by sector for example 54
supported nurses going on strike while a
figure dropped to 41 in favor of strikes
by rail workers
strike fatigue is a possibility but
there's little sign of it yet Paul
Brennan Al Jazeera London